Okay.
So what did they tell you about waves?
I said,
let's take a concrete example.
Instead of talking in generalities,
you say wave is the disturbance of some medium.
The medium I chose to study.
What's a string under some tension clamped at both ends.
Then you pull it and you release it.
It's going to be doing something
this height
from the normal position.
At the point x is the actual variable,
CFX and t.
So at every point x along the string,
that is a displacement of the string in the transfers direction.
That's my FX and T.
I showed you that this psi obeys the following equation.
The square psi over d x squared equals one over v squared,
B squared,
psi over Dt Square.
Where we square is tension divided by mass per unit length.
I'm going to chain meditation into force because tea is also used for time
periods.
So it's gotta be,
it's gotta get me in trouble very soon.
So let's just end the formula to watch.
Use the books.
Vesquez fo reveal f is the tension on the string.
So what does,
how did we get this?
Let me remind you how I got this.
Okay,
let's Undo The v square as a tea over meal.
What we're saying is t v squared,
PSI over dx squared is equal to mu.
These squares psi over Dt Square.
This is very easy to understand.
Meaning of the equation I clean is just f equals m.
A you realize that this is the a of the string.
Moving up in all this,
the acceleration and this is the mass but unit length,
so imagine a tiny segment of with Dx,
if you multiply both sides by Dx,
that is a massive,
a little segment.
New Times the is the mass.
This is mass times acceleration.
The left side is the force on it.
Why is this the force?
I tried to explain to you that if we took a piece of that string,
then the tension is pulling like that there and like this here and the two don't
cancel because if you resolve this force into vertical,
horizontal part that at the vertical horizontal part you can see this is going
to be bigger than that.
So it the slope itself is changing and this is the rate of change of the slow.
Well another way to think about it is if you remember your calculus,
the second derivative of a function is the curvature of the function.
So then if you draw a graph like this,
that's the function of negative curvature.
That's the comm function.
This positive curvature,
it stays.
If the string has negative curvature,
the force is down string as positive curvature.
That's probably means you are below your normal position.
Then it's getting a force upwards so it's the curvature of the string that leads
to a net force.
One of you asked me very good question and after class,
which is the question was you took care of the vertical forces as d sine theta
plus Delta data here and t signed data here and you did all the cancellation.
How about the horizontal part?
That's also not quite balanced being the angles that aren't equal but the point
was cited or was approximated by Taito for small angles but cost sine theta.
You guys remember beacons is one minus data squared over two and so on,
but we are not keeping track of things more than the first part of data and the
calculation.
So of course saint data is just one in this approximation and tempted,
I am scientist are both equal.
The data,
that's a small angle approximation.
That's why the horizontal forces,
the fact that they don't quite match,
it's an error to next audit and data,
but the vertical forces are proportional.
The first part of data and that's what we can,
that's the origin of the wave equation.
Then you know you did the cancellation of x and so on and you went back that
far.
Then I said,
how about solution to this equation?
Well,
if you
have a little more time,
I can tell you how to get the solution does equation,
I don't have that much time.
So what we would do is going to do is to be content with writing down a solution
then convincing you it's a solution analyzing his properties.
So solution I wrote down look like a ghost sign,
k x minus Omega t and I said,
well is that a solution of this farm?
We'll take it,
put it into the equation and take all the data vendors.
First of all,
you guys should be able to see that the will cancel on both sites.
You see that?
So if you put this here to deliver,
this will pull out a case square today.
Riveters here we'll put out an Omega squared.
Therefore,
if you want the two sites to match,
you will want the Omega squared side divided by the square to equal the case
where that means Omega equal to k times v.
That's the only condition.
If that is satisfied,
this,
if this Omega escape times to you have a solution.
Yeah,
no,
and a
stand for anything
you're going to have any amplitude you want.
Of course,
that's a little bit of a fake.
Why is that not really literally true?
What's,
Yep.
Positive.
Real.
No,
I tell you it's real and positive and two miles long.
Yes.
Yeah.
Not only that,
the whole calculation assumed it was a small displacement problem,
right?
That's why Saint [inaudible],
Raleigh qualitate and cost data as roughly one.
So once you make an approximation and you get an answer,
you should not blindly or play the answer to circumstances that are not valid.
So even though the answer says you can have any aid that you like in practice,
you shouldn't use it for today,
which is so large that a the small angle approximation fieldstone all right,
so hey is anything,
so let's put in the lesson I've learned,
namely that Omega is equal to kv and write it as Cape Times x minus v.
T.
And here's where we were at the end of the class.
What this tells you is that this guy is some function of x minus v.
T it happens to be a cost side but it turns out any function of x minus VT
actually satisfies the wave equation.
That's a really interesting exercise for you.
Calculus buff,
stick ef,
unknown function,
whatever you like,
but it's not an arbitrary function in with x and t up here any way they like,
they appear only in this combination,
so makeup,
any function like hyperbolic cosh of x minus Vt,
that's a solution.
The wave equation.
Why?
Because if you start taking derivatives,
if you call this variable w you will find that partial,
a little bit of an x and partial,
a little bit too with the aspect of t are all connected to the liberties of w
and then if you do the chain rule you will find the satisfies the wave equation.
Then I tried to convince you that because of that the is actually the velocity
of the wave.
Let me tell you why I take any function you like at a given time.
T equal to zero.
It has a certain shape.
Our coastline has a certain shape,
but take any shape you like at t equal to zero.
Let us say it just peaked here.
You see,
wait a little bit.
If you'd like to be picked at x equals six for example,
if you wait a little bit this term minus VT es,
subtracting it from it,
you've got to add to this the same amount so that the peak now will be there.
The Amman baby,
his mood is in fact exactly equal the bt other words,
VT becomes a nonzero extra become non zero by the same amount.
If he wanted to ride the crest of that wave,
that means the signal is moving to the right,
so it turns out you can have x minus v t rx plus bt.
They're both solution.
The wave equation with a minus sign,
the signal is moving to the right with a plus sign is moving to the left.
That's a summary of what I did last time.
So last time we did have,
the way we question we
took this particular solution.
All right.
The next thing I want to do
is ask the following question.
What is k and what does Omega,
so let's take this function side off.
X and t which is a course sign,
k x minus Omega t
c a function or two variables is hard for us to visualize.
You're all good at explaining,
visualizing the function of one variable,
but this is a function of two variables.
Understand why it's to every point on the string has available site at that
point and that variable can vary with time.
That why sigh of x and t is needed to describe the vibration off an extended
body like a string.
For a [inaudible],
you just need one or two or three coordinates.
All right,
now I look at this function and I say,
let me at least understand this function or t equal to zero
t equal to zero.
Drop that term.
In other words,
this is a snapshot of the function.
What does it look like?
If I take a picture of t equals zero then I bury space.
Well that's cool.
Sign x and you can all plot [inaudible].
KX versus x is going to start out at a then it's going to oscillate because
that's what the coastline does.
No,
this distance from one peak for the next peak we call the wavelength.
It's halted the distance from one truck to another truck foot from one point to
an identical point.
That distance where you repeat yourself is called lambda.
What is the relation of care to lambda?
Now you got ask yourself when x was zero,
this angle was zero.
I got increased x two let's come back to what's essentially zero portico sign.
You are back to essentially zero if this angle is two Pi can answer before by
our six by,
but the first time you're back to zero is when it's too pie.
That for the length lambda I have,
there has a property that k times lambda is two Pi because if I move to the
right by Nmr Lambda,
the angel and the cost center change by two points,
so there's number call.
Kay is related to the number we all understand more intuitively by this formula
is the inverse of the wavelength up to this factor two Pi.
Now you can say,
well you picked time t equals zero.
Maybe if you pick time Tiqualu one second,
you would have gotten a different picture.
Think about it if a party called one second,
as long as it's the fixed number that's on fixed angle Phi,
that's just going to shift the whole pattern by some amount.
It won't change the fact that the peak to peak distance is still lambda
because what's happening as a function of time,
we have seen very generally is that this whole pattern is going to slide to the
right.
So I want to combine this picture with a dynamic picture of is saying,
if you know very time,
imagine this sliding by.
If you were sitting somewhere and here are some point,
that'd be the height for you and as time goes by,
that'll be the height and that'll be the of that.
It'd be the heightened.
That'll be the,
hey,
all these things will go past where you are.
So let us know.
Ask,
what does it look like to a person sitting at a certain location as a function
of time?
In other words,
the waves are being manufactured in the ocean.
Let's say they're being sent towards the shore.
You stand in one place,
the wave's going to go past you,
so you will Bob up and down.
And that's what I want to understand.
So I picked some location.
I pick x equals zero for convenience than sy at x equals zero as a function of
time.
Looks like Eiko Sine Omega t I didn't miss the minus sign put of course sign.
It doesn't matter if you change the angle,
the minus the angle.
So block the same graph.
Now this time as a function of time
and ask what happens?
Well,
you start with a maximum and you Bob up and down.
This is a picture of at one point where the water or the string goes up and
down.
So we like to call this from one maximum to the next maximum.
The pain period.
That's the time.
What would it be?
Is the way repeats itself.
Okay.
Well it follows then that Omega Times,
the time period is two Pi because when I put little tickle the time period,
I've gone from this maximum.
Does that make sense?
Therefore ah,
Omega is two Pi over t in other words,
Kay and Omega,
which we put into the wave unrelated to the time period and the wavelength to
this reciprocity formula.
Yeah,
so if you'd like,
you can ride the wave as a course sign to buy x over lambda minus two pipe t
over capital t they're strictly equivalent.
You write it any way you like.
This makes it clear that have been exchanges by lambda.
Nothing happens to the coastline because my next changes by land or you're
adding a two part of the coastline yet it's clear that if you add the little t
and amount of time,
big t nothing happens because two pis don't matter.
So this,
this makes it very clear the periodicity in space and time,
but this is more compact because we don't want to caddy two pies and lambdas in
this complicated form.
Me Give a new name to two pie over lambda and two Pi over t.
Okay.
What about the velocity of the way you remember it satisfies this condition is
Omega over k
but no.
Let's rate this in terms of this new guys.
Two Pi over t divided by two Pi over lambda is lambda over tea.
Okay,
so the velocity of this,
this wave is called a sign wave,
but of course sign way about a plane wave.
You got to understand waves and water than waves and string always have a
velocity.
If you pluck the string and let it go,
a little blip will travel from left to right,
but not every wave has a wavelength all the time.
Period.
This is a special function that has periodicity and t.
In other words,
if you go to the lake and drop a rock,
you'll set out some waves and after a while they'll spread out.
It's not going to happen over and over and over again,
but if you want the wave to be present for all time,
for all space,
you should keep on agitating the water.
That's what be imagine here is the source of this wave is to keep manufacturing
these waves from left to right.
So you must remember that in general,
every wave on a string art in the medium has a velocity,
but not every wave has a wavelength all the time period.
Any policies that traveled from left to right with speed V is a possible
displacement of the medium.
That's a particularly simple situation.
We study for that simple situation.
The velocity is connected,
the wave length and time period in this fashion or do you may also like to write
it as lambda times frequency.
So that's a very easy thing to remember because you've a trend to get a velocity
is going to be some distance over some time.
The only distance you can think of for those pediatric wave as a wave length,
the only time you can think of is the time it turns out the lambda over to is in
fact simply the velocity.
Here's another way to understand this.
Supposed to have a string that goes on to infinity and I'm catching it at this
end and I start wiggling the string.
When I started wiggling this,
these pulses will travel.
Let us sell their,
come up to this point.
Let's wait one more second in one more second.
I would have manufactured a few more of these pulses and the wave will look like
that.
How many posts would I make per second?
F?
How long is each one lambda?
So that's how much it the wave as advanced in one second.
That's why it's the velocity you're making lambda sized objects,
f at the time,
F per second,
and pushing them out.
So the front of the wave of advances a distance,
lamb die if in one second.
That is the philosophy.
That's one way to understand why lambda f is equal to v.
Okay,
so now I considered another aspect of these waves and that's the energy in the
wave.
First of all,
you've got understand a vibrating string has some energy compared to a string
with the not vibrating,
okay?
You have an intuitive feeling.
The vibrations that are cost of energy.
I want to calculate now the energy in a string vibrating according to this
formula here,
my was it infinitely long string.
The energy unit is infinite,
so you don't define the energy of an infinitely long string.
You defined the energy off a piece of string.
In fact,
you talk about energy per unit length.
So if you take a string,
it's been vibrating for a long time and the waves have been manufactured on the
left,
they've gone out far to the right.
We don't care how far.
Take a portion of the string
off length dx and ask how much energy does it have?
Yeah,
what it is seen that if you sit at one point,
the string just moves up and down it execute simple harmonic motion.
When the string has gone all the way fully,
it's like a spring,
which has been extended maximally.
That's when the string stops,
turns around and comes back.
When the string has come to the horizontal position,
that's the normal equilibrium position for a mass on a spring.
That's when it's moving the fastest and overshoots and goes to the other side
and goes back and forth.
So every part of the string is just undergoing simple harmonic motion.
That's pretty obvious from this.
So we just need to write down the energy.
So how do you write the energy?
The energy
is going to be either candidate or potential are the sum of the two?
No,
you can find the energy when nobody would like,
because it's a constant,
let's find it.
When the velocity is a maximum,
like for harmonic oscillator is like finding the velocity when the mass is just
swinging past the normal position x equal to zero.
They had the entire energy is kinetic energy.
It's one half new DX is the mass of the segment.
I'm looking at.
What's the maximum velocity you guys remembered from harmonic oscillators?
What's the maximum velocity that a harmonic oscillator has?
Who's a motion has given by this?
Yep.
Yes.
Uh,
Omega,
this is getting a Yale education.
So that's the difference between the $40,000 and $10,000 is that this is not a w
but omega.
Okay.
By the way,
I,
I could not get any of my kids to say,
uh,
Omega.
They keep saying,
W I'm trying to have more success with this class then with my own offspring.
But if you go to the outside world,
if you talk to any physicist,
if you say w they would think you're talking about the width of something.
So you have to say Omega is the Greek alphabet is essential to communication.
So this is a Omega is the maximum velocity and I got a square to that.
No,
this is the energy office segment of a length dx.
So what we normally define as a quantity called literally you and that is the
energy,
but unit length,
that means you just divide by the x and you get one half meal.
A Square Omega Square.
Okay.
It is just the kinetic energy offers segment of unit length.
It's the,
it's the total energy.
But I chose to computer winners all Kennedy.
Yes,
mew is the mass,
but unit length.
Do you understand your take the string you find mass,
any divide by legs that some somewhat Matt's per centimeter.
Per meter.
That's me.
That's what,
if you go back to the derivation of the wave equation,
we were thinking in terms of mute.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now we can ask another question.
What does the power center into this wave by the person exciting the media.
See the string,
uh,
is tied to a point appointed infinity.
But let's say they started oscillating a while ago and this is the part of the
string that has started moving and I'm still shaking it here.
Let me wait one second if it,
wait one second.
This part of the spring is now activated.
And what's the energy contained in the extra segment?
There's the energy per unit length one half mew is where Omega square times the
velocity.
Yeah.
That is the power I have to give in to produce this wave continuously.
You guys follow that?
If I wait one second,
a segment of lengthy has now started moving in the front end.
I got the wave is being produced by me and sent out into the medium.
The distance it travels in one second is v and all of that extra segment is no
vibrating with this energy per unit length.
So this is the extra energy per second I have to give and that's the power.
That power is provided by the person shaking the string.
A special property of life in one dimension is that this way of goes on
diminished and amplitude.
You can go 10 miles,
100 miles from me.
Amplitude is still the a that I produced here.
That's because all the energy goes along this line.
The sort of atypical,
what typically happens is when you live in,
when you take into account vibrations of the sound in two or three dimensions,
if you have a power on top of it,
you put a that's making noise.
The energy radiates out in concentric circles
and the power of the source is now spread over bigger and bigger spheres.
So in three dimensions we have the notion of intensity,
which is the power,
but unit area.
What I'm saying is if you've got a speaker,
they are sending out sound waves.
I take a one meter by one meter window in hold in front of me and ask how much
power across this in one second.
That intensity.
You don't have the notion in one dimension because you cannot hold a window in
one dimension.
Okay?
Three dimensions.
You take a little squared,
one by one meter,
and you'd define intensity to be powered between the data.
Of course,
it doesn't have to be one meter big.
You can take a tiny square provided divided with the area of the tiniest square.
That is this.
So what do you think will happen if there's a speaker motor on top of a platform
that's radiating power at the Red p?
The intensity you get value are,
I hope you understand will be simply for PR square,
but artists,
the radius of the sphere and you are a distance art from the center and the
power is going or do uniformly now are all directions and your share for the
whole sphere with Spi,
the share for a unit area on the sphere is p divided by four Pi r squared
and that's measured in watts per meters squared.
Yes.
People's health.
Anyways,
Omega squared,
this one,
uh,
what else do you think it should have?
T four time period.
Why?
That's energy for lane
is energy per length.
But if I wait one second,
the way of has gone a distance v Times one second.
And so the extra energy I given every second has to pay for be more meters.
That's the interview for a second.
Yeah.
This is the energy per second.
That's the power.
That's correct.
So if you take your unit,
you will find it.
It's got a energy per second.
Okay,
so this is called the intensity.
And for sound,
we have another way to measure the intensity.
We defined something called Beta,
which is 10 times the logarithm of the intensity divided by a standard
intensity.
The standard intensity has a value 10 to the minus 12 watts per meters squared.
And this is called the desert number of decibels.
So you mentioned the loudness of the sound in decibels.
You must have heard that everywhere you look at your,
or even your amplified,
it'll have so many dbs in it.
So what's the DB talking about?
The dbs says your speakers making some,
uh,
sending out some energy.
Stay about ever.
You want at a certain distance from the speaker.
See how much poverty is passing pastor unit area.
That's the numerator divided by the standard number.
People all agreed on dividing by the standard.
Then take the logarithm of that to the base 10 and multiply by 10
that's called the number of disabilities.
So for example,
if the power coming to me was the 10 to the minus 11 watts put meters square,
then I owe what I not,
what would it be?
10 to the minus 11 divided by 10 to the minus 12 which will be 10 to the one and
log of gender.
The one is just one and Beta will be 10
DB.
So 10 decibels sound is a factor of 10 bigger than the standard song.
But here's the interesting thing.
Suppose the intensity is 10 to the minus eight
watts per meters squared.
That is a thousand times more intense than this one.
But let's look at Beta.
Beta victims 10 log off pen to the fore now because 10 to the minus eight
divided by 10 to the minus 12 is 40 so when the intensity goes from some number
to something thousand times bigger,
the decibel goes from 10 to 40
the decibel grows much more slowly than the actual intensity.
In fact,
the disabilities keeping track of how many Zeros that are in the power,
it grows logarithmically.
So every time I add an extra zero to the power,
you go from 10 to a hundred a hundred to a thousand decibel goes up just by from
10 to 20 to 30 to 40
that's why 80 disability can be incredibly low.
80 90 a hundred hundreds of very painful number of decibels,
and I believe people use decibels because the human ear is able to take a whole
range of intensity and hear it.
The ability of the ear to listen to intensity.
You might think that's a very narrow band.
You can see here we can hit a very wide band,
but the intensity ranges over several powers of 10 in that case,
yes,
of dealing with numbers that go all the way from 10 to the minus five to tender,
the plus something you dealing with the logarithm or the number,
then it's more manager.
So you can imagine trivial problems involving finding better given Beta,
finding the intensity and so on.
Okay,
so now,
uh,
I'm finished with this basic properties of waves.
That's it both as the property just for sound,
you don't apply that to light and the whole standard intensity I not intensity
as well defined for everything.
Even electromagnetic waves of intensity.
It's the power coming per unit area.
But when applied to sound,
if you take the log and multiply by 10 that's the decibel level of that song.
Okay.
Now for another totally different property of wave propagation,
which I'm going to again,
I played the sound is the family adopted ethics.
So the doppler effect as though well known phenomenon that if you have a source
of definite frequency,
like a siren,
you know fire truck,
when the fire truck is coming towards you,
you hear a higher frequency and when it's gone past you,
you hit a lower frequency.
Again,
we just want to know why and by how much.
So to proceed with this,
I wanted him mind you,
this relation lamb that times f this v.
So we are going to bear that in mind.
So let's take a source that is sitting still and you are standing here listening
to the song.
The waves go by you and you see a certain wavelength.
That's the distance from one crest or the next.
Now suppose the source is moving to the right at a certain speed.
You use the speed of the source.
Yeah.
So what does the pattern look like?
It's not too hard to visualize that having limited at one crest,
it's moved to the right before image,
the second crest.
So the pattern,
we'd get crunched in the forward direction like this.
So the waves will get squashed because the spacing would have been lambda,
but now it's less than lambda because it's moved to the right to emet.
The second crest,
the spacing from crest to crest,
the new lambda we take called lambda prime,
little bit lambda minus the distance.
The source travels in that time.
The time it takes to him at one more both.
That is the time period.
So let me write it as lambda minus you would f
yes.
Yeah.
T is one over f.
So what does the new frequency that I will hear the new frequency,
I would hear it with the velocity divided by the new wavelength.
By the way,
you got to understand that even though the sources moving to the right,
the velocity of sound is not altered by that process.
A moving truck does not emit sound at an increased speed in the forward
direction or decrease.
The speed of sound is controlled by the medium in which it travels.
The medium is air.
It's going to travel only at that speed so you don't have a new velocity when
the thing begins to move.
But of these,
the same in address,
as long as the ad is not moving.
So let's write it as v or lambda minus you or what?
F multiplied top and bottom by f.
So we write it as f time something which is v divided by lambda,
f minus U.
And we fiddled with that and write it as B divided by B minus you because
lambda,
FSV and white,
top and bottom by B.
This is something you will find in every possible textbooks.
I don't want to take too long to go over the details.
The main trick isn't writing this equation.
Once you got this,
the rest of it,
it just uh,
Algebra.
The point is to realize that the waves get crunch because when you emit the
crest and you rush towards that crest and Emmett,
the second crest,
you've reduced the spacing by your velocity multiplied by the time between
certain emissions,
which is the time of vibration of the siren.
So this is the formula.
The frequency is the normal frequency divided by one minus something.
So one minus something is less than one.
So the frequency will go up if you want to see what happens here behind the
thing,
you have the option of doing the same calculation behind and I think it's very
obvious what will you will find.
You will get one plus something.
So we'll write both solutions minus or plus.
In one case,
the frequency will be increased.
Other cases the frequency will be decreased.
So one way to think about it is if the source is coming towards you,
use the minus sign.
If the source is going away from you,
you use the plus sign,
but you should know intuitively at least what signed to pick.
You got to know if the sources coming towards you,
the frequency will go up and was going away from you.
It'll go down.
So you pick the signed using that common sense.
Somebody had a question in the back.
Yes.
Ah,
relativistic speeds.
A lot of things happen.
That's correct.
When you are handled light,
you've got to be very careful the last year of lady with the velocity of light.
But the frequency will change for many reasons.
First of all,
the ambulance clock and your clock no longer agree.
So that is something called a transfer as doppler shift to where even if it's
not coming towards you or going away from you,
but it's going in a circle,
you're sitting in the middle,
it's going tangentially,
so it's not coming towards you or away from you.
You will still feel a doppler shift.
That's because it's a moving clock and therefore it'll slow down.
So relativistic problems are more complicated.
Yes.
Okay.
Sonic boom comes in in the following thing.
F prime is f divided by one minus you Overbey.
Let me embellish.
Formula Writing,
user base.
But s means source.
Okay.
When the sources moving,
this is the formula in relativity.
It was chocked full of formulas like this,
but we never worried about what happens.
So the denominator vanishes because you just cannot approach the speed of light.
You can approach it,
but he cannot reach it.
But the speed of sound is not a upper limit at all.
And you can have an ambulance or a plane that eventually travels faster than
this.
So that's when imagine the waves getting crimes.
Still all the crests that pilot right on top of each other and that's when that
is the sonic boom.
And if you go faster than that,
the way the wave led sandwiches from you so that you leave behind a trail,
there's nothing in front of you.
So if a jet plane is coming towards you faster than the speed of sound,
you won't have time to get out of the way because it'll hit you before the sound
waves hit you.
Okay,
so sound is not the absolute limit.
So that are possibilities of,
I mean every time you would go into Concord,
well not anymore,
but when you did a,
you would be crossing this thing pretty soon after takeoff because you go
several times faster than the speed of sound.
Okay.
The last doppler thing I want to do is the opposite one where the Seitan is
everything nice spherical waves,
but you are rushing to meet the site.
You are going with the speed,
you've sub observer.
Then what happens?
So let's see what to do.
What's the frequency at which you will see Kress?
If you sat there and did nothing,
you will see them at the normal frequency.
But now you are
these waves that space,
the distance lambda apart.
But your velocity villa to the sound is now usually zero plus B.
Your relative velocity sound is moving to the right.
You are moving to the left.
So let's back with these crests.
You're zipping at a speed,
you're not plus v and the crest of spaced at distance lambda a partner.
There's nothing wrong with the spacing between them.
They are just like shown here.
You were just rushing to meet them.
Now from your side.
So how many will you intercept in a second is this,
this is the relative speed and that's lambda.
So let's write it as a not plus B.
Lambda is equal to B divided by F's.
I'll bring the f upstairs and that you can write us f times one plus you
observer over v.
So when you move towards the source,
the correction factors appears in the numerator.
When the source moves towards your correction factor appears the denominator,
right?
You got to use common sense disease that blesses it,
minus and so on.
It's pretty obvious if you're rushing to meet the waves,
it's plus if running it from the waves minus,
then you can go on and on and ask what happens if you are moving and the
ambulance is also moving,
then you can come by and the formulas.
But I don't want to do that.
That's not,
that's not the whole course dedicated to theory of sound.
But this is just to tell you how to reason in the two special cases,
source moving and observer moving.
Okay,
so now the rest of the class is going to be uh,
focused on one essential property of wave.
So the whole time I'm going to do this is one important property of waves that
have to do with interference.
A waves.
Look at the wave equation I wrote down.
It's a linear equation.
You see that?
Don't be fooled by this d two side.
That doesn't make a quadratic.
The first part of Cy on both sides.
Then do the following exercise in your mind.
Sight one is the solution,
side two is a solution.
Add the two equations,
you can check the site one plus it was also a solution.
So these waves also have the property that what that really means is the
following.
If you make some sound and you're sending some waves,
they make a certain pattern that travel through space.
Then I turn you off and I turn on another speaker here.
Let's say the speaker,
it makes us sound.
If the you and the speaker are making sound at the same time,
then the air displacement where I am will be simply the sum of the two.
So if one caused the one effect,
the second cause pretty the second effect then bought that turned on the way of
their produce would simply be the sun.
You can simply add them because that respects the satisfies the wave equation.
So all I'm going to do from now until end is tick,
but of situations where I'm going to be adding two waves,
the simplest problem is the following up because certain spot
you just sit there and listen to two waves so you're not going to look at the
wave as a function of space.
It's function of time.
Somebody is making the waves and sending them to you.
The first wave looks like psy one equal to AA because Omega one t that's the
second source of sound which is a cost or may got to tea.
I've chosen the two to have the same amplitude but not necessarily the same
frequency.
You want to add these two and you want to see what you hear
so what you will hear will be site one plus side too which will be a cost Omega
t plus cause Omega to t.
Yeah,
no you can do the trigonometry identities and figured out what had happened but
you have to think a little bit about what's going to happen.
Think about these two waves.
If they have the same frequency,
it's trivial,
right?
If they'll make out,
one is equal to Omega to cy is equal to a cause Omega t but omega is a common
frequency that that just means they reinforce each other at every instant.
You get double what you got before but if the frequency is not equal then
initially they are in step.
This question is one that goes sign is one at the amplitude as two way as time
goes by.
Omega one t and Omega to t start deferring to the core science or not in step
anymore and what can happen after a wireless.
The two questions are offset behalf of cycle are the angle between them as pie.
Then in fact they will cancel.
Then if you wait long enough again,
they will be in step.
One way to think about is imagine two runners going around in a track.
If they have slightly different speeds,
they start out together,
they go out on one start,
lagging behind the other and they will be on different parts of the circle and
the time will come and that an opposite parts of the circle when the opposite
parts of the circle,
the angular difference between them is pie and that's when we say they cancel.
If you wait long enough,
they'll again lineup but with one difference one guy would have done one more
evolution than the other.
Then again,
they will be in a,
in a in step and all this stuff.
That's what you expect the formula to give you.
So you got to go back and use the turn on magic formula and the answer it is to
a call sign or may go one minus Omega to forward food times.
T famous quote is sine Omega one less Omega to for two times thi this is a cost
a minus cost be is to cause a plus B over to cause a minus B over two.
All right,
so we are interested in the case,
but Omega one
is very nearly equal to Omega to
so two frequencies,
a very close,
typical situation.
Do you have a piano tuner?
Piano tuner hits their fork.
It vibrates on a frequency maybe for 40 hertz and then a European or slightly
off.
Maybe it's four 39 what sound do you hear when you put them together?
Well,
let's look at this if we'll make that one.
Minus Omega too is a very small number.
This course sign here is changing very,
very slowly.
This goes scientists oscillating at roughly the,
it's aspirating the average of the two frequencies.
So one was four oh one
and one was three 99 this is Austin eating at 400 but here Omega one lane is
Omega to is two divided by two is one so it's oscillating much slower.
So what will you get if you plot this?
Think of the whole thing as an amplitude,
the slowly varying with time.
Okay,
so we have done it the other day when I wrote either the minus gamma t over two
times some cosine Omega t.
This is an envelope.
The controls the amplitude.
That day it was falling monotonically but he had a little oscillate very slowly.
So let me apply this course sign here.
This is just the amplitude,
but would that amplitude,
this guy's oscillating like crazy.
So what I do mean to convey is that you will have oscillations like this.
So it'll be loud,
silent,
loud,
loud silence.
So you will hear another beat.
This is called the beat in which you will hear the hum in which together they
add and cancel and cancel.
And we want to calculate the beat frequency.
Now the first guest is to say the frequency of the beat.
There's Omega one minus Omega to over two because that's what seems to be here,
but actually the correct answer is the beat frequency is simply omega one minus
one may get to and I will tell you why I take will the zero when the co sign had
a value one you've got an amplitude to a
wait til omega one minus Omega two over two
is not equal to two pi but equal to Pi.
I'm in time Steve.
This whole combination is equal to Pi.
This number becomes a negative number of size to a,
that just means it's here.
But if you multiply that huge negative number by the cost side,
it is still isolating very wildly here as much as it is here.
In other words,
five course and Omega t and minus five courses and I get you have the same
amplitude.
The minus doesn't change the fact that it's having large excursions from plus to
minus five so in other words,
I'm telling you to compare some answer like this because 400 t minus five
because 400 t
plug this in plug that you'll find your 400 is a very rapid oscillations.
This has an amplitude as big as this one and the year is just picking up the
amplitude yet it's not picking up anything else yet.
It's just picking up the loudness of the sound.
So it will seem to be loud now and load there.
But once you've gone from here to here,
you only have to change the argument of this whole thing by Pi and not by two
Pi.
That's why the beat frequency then happens to be simply the difference in
frequencies.
All I ask you to do another take.
If you're not happy with this,
go home and do the following thing.
Why does vibrating at Omega one the other is vibrating at Omega to t find out
when the difference between the phase angles is equal to Pi.
Cause that's when this guy and that guy will cancel each other.
That's when you come here.
Then you ask yourself when they will come back to where they are.
Two point ask for when the difference in phases two Pi and you will find that
that occurs that the frequency,
which is what I told you,
so whether you,
you can,
if you found this factor of too confusing,
you got to understand the argument they gave you that in order for this thing to
sound just as loud as it did or t equals zero,
it's not necessary that this number come to to a good enough if it comes to
minus two way because minus two wait times of rapid course sign,
it's oscillating on top of their mind is to Alonso look like plus two you cannot
tell the difference.
So beat frequencies that used to tune instruments.
So what the piano tuner does is to strike the fork and strike the thing on the
piano and listened to the two.
If they are not quite mast,
you'll hear a slow harm that goes up and down in intensity.
You keep on fiddling with it until it goes away.
That's when you match the two frequencies,
so beat frequencies of a lot of interesting applications in physics.
In fact,
when you go to a radio station,
you know this station is what,
nine 60 megahertz or something?
No Way.
Your ears can hear that.
That's not the frequency of the sound.
That's the frequency of the signal that called the cadion wave.
Then you modulate with that but something and you produce some beaters,
the beads that we are able to hear.
Yeah.
Anyway,
this is something fairly simple trigonometry problem.
Now I will do slightly more complicated problem,
but I'm going to add two waves and we'll do a lot more of this in the next term,
but right now you're supposed to have first pass at this topic.
This is called the double slit experiment.
You have a source of waves here.
So
the source is so far away that you can treat this to be just parallel lines and
you hit the double slit,
namely an impenetrable barrier with two holes in it.
If you want to think of it as water waves and the erector the wall on the arrest
state,
but there are two holes.
So you know what happen,
right?
These two holes for themselves start generating their own waves
and you want to stand on the line here,
go up and down with an ask.
What's the water doing where I am?
So first,
take a point exactly midway between these two points.
What are you getting?
You're getting a signal from here and you're getting a signal from here.
Once signal travels that way are the troubles that,
do you understand that because you're symmetric located,
the two signals will be in step when they come to you
because they were on step when this front hit this double haul and started
making his own way of.
So these waves emitted in step,
they march along and come to you without at the same delay.
So when a crest from this reaches your crest,
from that retreat you drafted Rita's draft Rita.
So you just double the answer.
So here you will get a site will become to sy,
are able to become to a,
you've had an amply today from this and a from this you will get to eight here.
So the water will be very choppy there.
If you're living on a little board,
the board would rock up and down with amplitude to a,
if you shut off this whole ambulatory to go back to just that from one hole lady
be a two gives you two way.
That's what makes a lot of common sense.
But pick another point here.
I will tell you how to pick that point so that these two lengths are not equal.
So let's call that length l one and l two suppose l one minus l two is half a
wavelength.
As you know,
between every two crests,
that is a trough where the function is minus the amplitude at the crest of
secular plus the amplitude.
So if found half a wavelength apart when a crest from here appears at trough
from here will appear,
but a Trump for him here appears across from here will appear.
In fact in every instance,
whatever comes here minus of that will come here.
Let us understand why the way the way it travels is two pi x over lambda,
but x say measure from here for the other guy it is two pi times x prime over
lambda.
Explain experiment that link if that link is longer than this by lambda over
two.
Okay,
if this is x plus lambda over two,
look what you're getting extra two Pi Times lambda over two divided by lambda is
really costly enough Pi plus what the other person got.
But court Santa Pie added to eat pie added to anything changes the cost center
minus itself.
So the way to think about it as when you're half a wavelength behind coming from
here,
whatever.
This one does this,
this minus of that because shifting by half a wavelength is adding a pie to the
coastline.
I think apply the coastline changes to do minus its value at every instant.
Not only does Crestcom a traffic traffic comes with crest.
Every possible displacement comes to the minus of that from here and you get
nothing here.
So this is called an interference minimum.
Odd.
We say here the interference is constructive and here to say the interference of
destructors.
Yes.
How will you find the point of destructive interference?
It's a matter of simple geometry.
You measured that length and you mentioned that length.
Take the difference instead of equal the lambda over two
that's the first destructive interference.
That's a very interesting point to sit and look water.
It's telling you,
it says if you sit here with your board and the board won't move at all,
even though that our two holes letting waves and at that point that's the
principle behind noise cancellation.
You can actually cancel one sound with another sound if you bring the second
sound off behalf of cycle
so that if you had only one hole in the wall that you build between your little
estate and the beach and the way it is from here to rocking the board,
miraculously putting a second hole at the right place can actually calm the
waters where you are
and diminish somebody's blocks.
One of these halls,
water,
we get choppy again where you are,
it's the property of waves.
The two waves can lead to nothing but one way of cannot because two waves have a
chance of working against each other and canceling.
This is something you got to get very straight.
Now if I go further up here
to like reach a point where the difference in those two lengths is the full
wavelength,
then I'm back to being instead.
Of course the full wavelength means that these are not doing the same length,
but this is different from that by a whole wavelength.
That means when the 13th way from here arrives,
the 14th of the 12th from here will arrive,
but we don't care.
As long as the crest comes to the crest will be happy where we are.
So things get start with constructive,
destructive,
constructive,
destructive.
It oscillates both above and below the midpoint.
Yes,
yes.
How is the amplitude of the waves?
It could be it need not be the same.
It all depends on the aperture and so on.
But what is clear by symmetry is that these two have the same amplitude.
In practice,
we believe the amplitude will also be the same because amplitude has to be
continuous.
When you go through a slit,
the water cannot be jumping up to it just before the slit and suddenly on the
other side jump to a different lengths.
Amplitude is always continuous,
so in fact,
this amplitude in that amplitude will be equal.
You can also see from the wave equation,
if the site was not continuous,
this IDX will be infinity.
There's no room for any infinities in equation to Cybil you continuous.
In fact,
yes.
Here.
You're not able to read this equation because it's very badly written.
Let me tell you what I tried to do cause sine two pi x over lambda,
let's pick a certain time so that I've done.
We're able to make a tea.
In fact,
let me write it as l one the other one is cause sine two pi l two over lambda.
I'm adding two waves.
Suppose l two is equal to l one plus half a wavelength.
Then this one becomes a score sine two pi l one over lambda plus Pi.
Yes,
right.
L Two is l one plus lambda over two.
This is the l one.
If you put a lambo over two times to play with lambda,
you get a pie.
Then you got to understand that whenever he had applied to of course sign,
you get minus the cost side without the fine
and you can see this guy is producing a signal which exactly the minus of that
guy.
I did this at t equals zero but you can put an Omega t the boat,
but nothing changes.
The fact that when you subtract the same Omega t from the two,
it doesn't change anything,
so I didn't worry about the time.
It's the spatial mismatch.
That's the problem here.
Okay?
Now,
sometimes people write this formula for destructive and conscious constructive
interference as follows.
That's an approximate formula.
That's very handy.
The correct way to do this.
Of course,
the simply measure that distance and that distance and take the difference.
Okay?
In other words of l one minus l two is equal to m lambda,
but I miss an integer.
One,
two,
etc. Plus minus one plus minus two
it is constructive.
If it's a happened with you,
which we like to denote as follows and plus half lambda again and make,
we'll lose zero plus minus one.
Is that right?
A destructive
that we have writing Ms. Usually the standard symbol people use for integers Mnn
are common symbols for integers,
so if the PAP differences,
an integer multiple of lambda,
it's harmless.
If it happened to their multiple of lambda,
it's harmful,
meaning destructive.
The whole approximation has to do with what does l one minus l two one is to
actually measure these lengths.
Exactly and using Pythagoras Theorem,
uh,
given the distance between the slits given the distance to the screen,
if that business is d one can do the math and calculate it,
but here is what people do.
They say imagine this screen is very,
very far away,
very far away so that the rays leaving this or actually parallel because they
admitted infinity and that's where your screeners,
it's not really an infinity but part enough for this purpose.
Then you can tell very easily that the extra length traveled by this way,
it was just this part here.
You see that cause this part cancels out,
so drop a perpendicular here.
Those two are equal in length going got infinity.
That's the extra section.
How long is the extra section with that is the distance between the slits.
If that angle is data here,
then we say these scientists
is equal l one minus l two,
and that's what you want to be that an lambda are mplus one half lambda for
constructive and destructive.
But that's a way to relate this data here to this direction.
They are the same angle.
Oh,
you might want to go look at your book where the graphics are better than mine,
but I'm telling you the same old trick we use from incline planes.
If you've got two lines,
this line and this line,
the angle between them is data than the perpendicular.
The two lions have the same angle between the perpendicular to this line is this
one and the perpendicular to the screen as a horizontal one.
So data is also that angle.
Therefore the way you will do any of these problems is suppose someone says find
out when I get the first destructive interference,
given that length to the screen and someone says,
how far should I move?
What do you do is you said d is the distance between the two slits.
Scientists equal to say lambda over two for destructive solve for theta because
d is known.
Scientific data is not known.
You wanted to be lambed over to lambda will be given to you.
Once you get the angle,
you're basically telling the person to go at that angle.
And that's where the intensity will be a minimum.
But then it's trigonometry to understand the d over l is just Stan data.
So if you knew theater,
you can find the over there.
So Overdale is Stan data.
So the problems you can get are either lambdas given to you and Ted,
as we found that data is given to lambda has to be fought.
Somebody can say in some experiment with waves,
I find the first minimum at that angle.
What's the wavelength?
The distance between the slits is so and so.
But the basic idea is really to find the path.
Links take the difference Saturday equal to either integrate multiple and half
and it did multiple other wavelength.
Okay,
last of the interference problem has to do with all these musical instruments
and it goes like this.
Take a string.
Now there's a wall here and you start shaking it and ask what happens.
So let's say I shake it just once and a send a pulse like this,
moving to the right.
Well this pulse,
by the time it gets to this place where the string is an is anchored and not
free,
the more it cannot vibrate here,
so how was that going to happen?
Well some forces will be exerted on the string by the wall to make sure that the
signal the walls sends out along with a signal you send out,
add up to zero at the point of contact because nobody operation that is a lot.
The result of that instead of an a signal goes out like this,
it comes out reflected and direction and inverted entered sign.
For those of you who want a more satisfactory proof of this,
let me say the following.
Suppose there was no wall.
I saw you send a signal and I manufacture admitted image of that to the right.
Traveling towards this point,
the two are coming near each other and when they meet by design I've arranged it
so that this one or this one when they overlap are exactly opposite of each
other,
so then they cancel each other at this point.
Then they go through each other and this will come out here.
That'll go to the other side,
but throughout this encounter,
here's the punchline.
Throughout the encounter,
this point was not asked to move
because the two waves cancel.
That means even if I put my finger there,
it won't Mac make a difference to this problem because that point is not
planning to move anyway.
It also means that if you put a battery in here that doesn't,
I love the string to move.
It doesn't change the outcome.
That's the reason we convince ourselves that incoming pullets this way comes out
that way.
Okay.
Now what I want to study,
it's not a single one shot pulse.
The pulse that looks like this,
a cause.
KX minus Omega t,
a continuous signal goes in.
How does it come out?
It comes out cause or mega t plus Kx,
so I've reversed the amplitude and I would reverse the direction of motion.
Yeah.
This is the result of an incoming with and the one that sent back by the wall
together.
They coexist.
That goes into,
that comes out and together they form.
What I will find in this region.
I keep sending stuff to the wall while keeps sending that back to me and both
exist,
but you got to do another trigonometry identity to show you that this is really
to signed k x Sine Omega T.
I don't want to go through the trigonometry identity,
but what I want you to notice them is that the resulting physics looks like
this.
Here is a wall
at at a given point x,
the amplitude,
the stew is signed k x and it also led to the frequency Omega t and if you draw
signed k x,
it's going to look like this.
Yeah,
so whenever Kx is equal to Pi,
it kicks equals Pi.
When that distance is lambda over to that is no vibration.
There's is no vibration.
This is called a node in between us.
An antidote,
this kind of thing will be set up all the way back.
Now you'll see what that means,
so at this point is not going to vibrate.
If put another barrier here,
it won't make any difference
because that point is these two waves add up to zero identically.
At that point,
if you put your finger there,
it won't matter.
So in addition to making a difference,
if you hold the string that it also doesn't matter if you hold it here.
So what that means
is that if you turn the problem around and say,
look,
I give you the following problem,
I give you a string which is clamped or these two m's,
what are the possible vibrations of the string?
They have to look like the following.
Your string length has to be equal to that or that or any of these multiples.
That means what can happen in your string.
It's either that or it can do that or something with more and more lobes in it.
These are the allowed modes of vibration of the string fixed the two ends.
What I want to extract from this is what sound while you're here,
what frequency will you here?
So you have,
this is the family of problems that you guys had expected to do.
So you have to think as follows.
That is the length.
How is the length related to the wavelength is all you got to figure out?
Is it clear to you guys that this is half a wavelength?
If you've got that you're home because you're saying half a wavelength is equal
to l or the wavelength is equal to two l the frequencies,
the velocity of sound divided by the wavelength,
which is velocity divided by two l.
That's the frequency you will hear from this guy.
When it vibrates like this,
I think it's clear to you that it's gone through one full cycle here.
This is a lambda equal to l you to the whole thing.
You will find frequencies.
Now v over l which is two times the lowest frequency which we did not buy,
f not,
which means the fundamental frequency
to the bottom line is very simple.
A string clamped,
the two ends and as linked l can only vibrate in either the fundamental
frequency or an integer multiple of the fundamental frequency and when it does
that,
the two ends of the string will be nodes and you can have any number of anti
notes in between provided you start with the node and end with the noise.
Now this is also valid in the following problem.
Take a tube clamp to both ends and that some longitudinal sound waves going back
and forth.
This is a transfers waves on a string.
This is sound waves going back and forth.
You realize the sound waves going back and forth cannot go back and forth at
this wall or this wall that for the motion of the ad molecules has to have a
node here and has to have an old here.
So the possible modes of vibration for sound for also look exactly like this
frequency.
This will be the same for vibrations on a tube close to two hands.
The only certainty which I want you to forget here at the picture really talks
about the string moving perpendicular to the length.
This is not indicate here that the sound,
the air molecules are going up and down.
This is the amplitude for longitudinal vibration.
If this number is three inches,
it made the molecules here,
I'm moving back and forth by three inches,
so be just out of habit.
Plot everything in the y axis.
That doesn't mean the motion is in the y direction for longitudinal wave.
The motion is side to side.
This is the extent of side to side motion.
Yeah,
so the only problem where you may get stumped as the following one,
I will tell you how to do that and then we're done.
Take it to
like this.
It's closed here and an open here.
Don't take a coke bottle or something and try to blow on it.
You hit a certain sound.
Why is it picking that one frequency?
That's what I want to understand now since I'm making the noise here,
here to spread the amplitude will be the biggest and of course that's not
nothing doing at this end because that's a wall which cannot go back and forth.
So what pattern can I draw?
Take a minute and think about it.
I want a maximum white British and he had nothing here.
The lowest one I can draw it looks like that.
The next one I can draw is constraint to have a maximum here and then a minimum
that end.
Now what is the relation of the length of that?
You put the wavelength.
I think you can see the length of that.
You know,
quarter of a wavelength.
You start from here to the top coming down as the other quarter.
Then the other half is missing.
So what's the frequency is equal to v over lambda?
It's going to be four V over L.
I'm getting the frequency to be velocity divided by wavelength than I bet you
will get this or did they get it wrong?
Ah,
yes.
I'm sorry.
Yes.
Be over four m four Ellis lambda.
Now what's the answer to here?
What is the relation of the lanes to wavelength?
The length happens to be a half a cycle.
Less than other quarter is three fourth of lambda.
Okay,
and the frequency,
if you do this will be three B over four l and this is all I want you to notice
that in this peculiar problem at one end is open in one end is closed.
The frequency is a odd multiples of the fundamental frequency.
Three times that,
five times that,
seven times there
and be in exams.
You can be asked,
but a depressant,
either this one or some other exam you take some time later in life,
you should be able to do the,
let me do one practice thing,
hit us up tube open at both hands.
Draw me the lowest frequency you can draw.
I want an antidote here and Antinori here,
but between them I got to have a node so I have to look like that.
Then you can brew more complicated patterns at provided the two ends look like
this and I think you can see here that this is half a wavelength.
So Eliquis lambed over two and again you will find here all frequencies are
interested in multiples of the fundamental.
So the story is this,
as long as the two ramps are the same,
both open are both closed,
all frequencies or integer multiples of the fundamental one.
If you've got a funny situation,
one end is open one and disclosed,
you will get odd multiples of the fundamental why.
I think you may have to go do some reading in the book.
I don't have a better way to explain this in the somewhat easier part of the
course,
and I think you should try to be on top of this particular topic.